the hard way ich habe jetzt meine
kommunen bekommen
meine kunden sind da da ist noch die
zweite kiste und jetzt werden sie
aufgebaut endlich denn seit wochen ist
mein zimmer zwar schon etwas schöner und
renovierte aber absolutes chaos weil ich
kein einziges möbelstück habe wo ich
dinge darin verstauen kann und das macht
alles sehr viel komplizierter ich habe
sogar schon für den stream hier etwas
schöner gemacht
falls sie nicht dabei gewesen seid im
livestream haben wir sogar die kommoden
live ausgesucht und wenn sie nicht so
schön sind wie auf den bildern dann
meine ich aber jetzt sind wir erstmal
auf
sie überlege gerade einfach so auf
zimmer einfach nicht alle verdienen
springt
ich bin mir nicht sicher habe ich glaub
jetzt schon aufgebaut
das heißt die andere ist auch viel
passiert dann seine dann
wieso das und schon immer als doch
irgendwas zu machen so die beine 3 pc zu
40 und so braucht man eine kommune auf
dankeschön fürs zuschauen bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss
also steht jetzt an dass hier das muss
weg das sollte gut erinnern das wollen
wir jetzt auf das gute ist das was er
hier ist kommt dann in die kommode rein
das ist meine lieblings kiste einfach
immer zur bank bringen
[Musik]
die zehn stehen das wünschen er irrte
sich mutti mutti mutti
[Musik]
irgendwie das gefühl man dies heute
verhandeln sollte aber warum sollten sie
einen was schicken was man noch
behandeln muss auf jeden fall gab der
bdv will ich den geruch beschreiben kam
es riecht gerade nach frischem holz
besitzt eingeräumt werden dass es zu
bauen interessant ich träumen sie jetzt
einfach ein und dann machen wir gleich
kommode nummer zwei daher müssen wir
erst mal den platz frei räumen
[Musik]
oder passt doch wunderbar also das ist
jetzt die schicksals kommode
sie heißt schicksals kommode weil sie
zusammen mit meinem lama bild
angepriesen wurde
ich habe mich noch nie in meinem leben
so schlau gefühlt ich bin so jawoll wird
jetzt doch die gewesen so nie wieder das
gleiche spiel die beiden aufbauende
hinstellt kino die schicksals kommode
war hauptmann händen verborgen ist so
praktisch damit so viel stauraum drin
sein
wir haben ein problem es gibt nämlich so
aus dass sowie die möbel grad stehen sie
mir nicht gefallen da fehlt das gewisse
eine extra überlege ich gerade die
kommode nach oben zu schieben die couch
und die kommode noch da wenn sonst nix
ist dann oder die kommode dahin und die
einfach da ich hasse ist hat sich nicht
entscheiden kann ich glaube ich muss
jetzt mal staub saugen
[Musik]
gucken dass schon alles voll sind ja für
diese innere klaren kwh was cent weniger
nicht so für den lift in württemberg zu
sagen hat ist da
[Musik]
ja das letzte mal habt ihr uns kommoden
umstellen sehen jetzt haben wir final
entschieden warum auch wir aber wir
haben final entschieden wo die möbel
stehen sollen und heute geht es an
pflanzen und regale
da muss leben denen die wohnung kann
hier haben wir eine wunderschöne ecke
und ein wunderschön timo hier ist noch
nicht so schön da habe ich aber auch bei
ikea gerade hof gekauft also wir waren
gerade bei ikea sind einfach in einem
leeren ikea keiner hat bock morgens um
10 zum ikea zu fahren was brauchen wir
wir brauchen die kleinen wunder
wunderschön aber hat du kannst du
trotzdem bekommen und der schreibtisch
steht jetzt hier der stand vorher so da
richtig hässlich
[Musik]
ganz klasse gemacht und dann haben genau
hier an
träger aber das kommt der weg endet so
plan for today das hier ist der
hintergrund von meinem stream und das
bild ist sehr schön aber ich möchte hier
zwei regale aufstellen an schrauben und
wir haben pflanzen gekauft dann so
herunter hängen können und dann kam noch
ganz viele pflanzen hier hat ich lasse
es frieder unser neues haustier da kommt
auch noch ein regal
[Musik]
beide linien frage und das mit genau der
gleichen höhe
wenn du irgendwo dort genau auf diese
sind jetzt schauen wieder abstand vom
staat zu bekommen
dort ist direkt auch zu passieren kann
43 cent reduziert werden
[Applaus]
später dazu die rauch fertig und wir
bauen für die wandlung ist video
vorläufiges ende
heute wird ihnen das leben
[Musik]
wir haben alle regale aufgebaut
das problem ist nur wir haben keine
schrauben und keine dübeln das heißt wir
müssen jetzt noch mal los in den
baumarkt jetzt für diese schrauben
entschieden das sind quasi unsere
lieblings
doch bei einem bohrer so schnell so
viele leiden treffen müssen schlag
cholera sterben
[Musik]
wir sind cool team kann sich ein bäcker
sachen obwohl ich gar nicht kann obwohl
es wirklich bist schön dicht kann
[Musik]
perfekt in der waage geteilte arbeit du
sagst ich finde ich werden
[Musik]
oh mein gott zu solchen kaffee haben wir
sollten kaffee haben und du kümmert sich
um die innere richtung david bibel
ich bin so überrascht wie gut es sich um
ein unglaublich was liegt ihm nach so
führt eco in die ecke ist dann nehm mir
noch nicht so durch gedacht oder das
bild muss er eben verrückt werden weil
der abstand zum regal müsse hier den
gleichen abstand haben und das bild
würde direkt unterm unterm rad sitzen
meinte dazu wenn ich auf noch mehr nähe
aber ich immer leser vielleicht einfach
weil das fenster herunter hängen
wieso dann über gefällt und dann gucken
wir was mit dem bild machen
[Musik]
empirie diene
wir machen wir heute erst mal schluss
und beim nächsten mal seht ihr dann wie
wir bilder an die wand machen und noch
viel mehr umstellen und gestalten ich
hoffe ihr seid dabei und wir sehen uns
das nächste markt bis dahin tschüss
genießt das gute wetter als bei euch
gutes wetter ist
[Musik]